so what I'm going to talk about today is
something that was referenced briefly
this morning at least three speakers
made fun of angry birds and talked about
how they wish people would do things
other than play video games and what I'm
going to talk about is why video games
are probably the single most interesting
thing happening in behavioral sciences
today warning i come from Silicon Valley
I'm not in medicine i'm not in physics
i'm not in the government we tend to do
really small things and then talk about
how important they are so warning ok
what's the small thing we're doing this
is a screenshot of a game called clash
of clans clash of clans on a daily basis
consumes somewhere between 50 and 100
million hours of humanity's time and
what it is is you build things and you
attack your friends and you know you
there's factories and resources and
there's a social communication layer and
most importantly from the perspective of
my company there's this notion of a
virtual currency you get the game for
free and then in the game you buy
currency that you then spend on in-game
items so as I move my own apologies for
the varying volume but basically who
here has seen this game or a game like
it who here has played this game okay we
got one person who played the game but
about half a you have played a game like
it from that description and the
important thing here is there's a
currency system you buy gold coins to
buy a lick sir do you spend them in the
game there's a whole set of pricing and
as a whole set of economic decisions
that get made within the game by each
and every person playing it and again
remember roughly 50 to 100 million hours
a day and as a result of that what
you'll see is that there are retail
strategies in this space the game on the
left is a game called bubble mania they
sell gems and 22 gems cost 99 cents or
you know there's a flash sale happening
if you haven't spent any money in the
game the game actually detects whether
or not you're a highly engaged user who
is unlikely to monetize and if it does
so then it puts a sale in front of you
and over on the right you'll see another
notion defaulting with special labels
and so on and so forth and so the
problem my company solves as our first
problem and the small thing we are doing
now is how many gems for how much when
you deal with commerce on a micro level
inside a game how much money do you
spend or how much money do charge and
how much do you sell pretty small thing
right everyone gets the problem we're
trying to solve how do you do dynamic
pricing on a personalized level within a
video game it goes much bigger though
fifty-eight percent of Americans play
video games globally it's the same
number by the way in places where there
are cell phones this is not children the
average age of a player is 30 sixty-two
percent of all gamers are adults dot dot
in the average u.s. gamer age 13 or
older spent six point three hours a week
playing video games last year so what
we're looking at is sixty percent of
americans spent an hour a day playing
mobile games and you stare at that
anything wow they're all free they're
all having these virtual currency
systems we have an enormous treasure
trove of behavioral data here and that's
the key thing because we're going to try
and figure out how much to charge and
how do you do that you start by just
going oh my god there's a lot of
information there are eighteen thousand
different types of android phones
there's all sorts of census information
etc everyone does this so we start with
why isn't it small because it's a huge
huge huge data set there's more
information about video games than there
is about almost anything else and when
people talk about the Internet of Things
you know globally we're talking about a
billion people carrying cell phones and
playing games that's a billion sensors
on human behavior so if you look at it
another way Tencent is an enormous
company in China they essentially own
twitter facebook and chat in china and
yet mobile games are where they make
their money
so it's a big big profit center as well
and then finally there's almost no
systematic research on how to do this so
if you go and I'm just going to go
forward for a moment airlines started
doing dynamic pricing the ability to
segment user bases in charge based on
user characteristics and the 70s and
they had all these if you go and read
the theory and practice of revenue
management quick check no I have it's
one of the things I did when I was in
the IR there's all sorts of facts here
right it's a highly competitive market
there are alternative suppliers you
can't make more seats on demand and by
the way when the plane takes off you can
no longer sell the seat it's an
infrequent purchase it's a large dollar
purchase and you know there is no
training you know if people have a
really good experiencing buying an
airline seat they will not buy more you
know that's not what they do ray I
really enjoyed my flight I think I'll
take another flight next week just not a
behavior that people really have people
have expectations on how much an
airplane costs right how much an airline
flight costs and customer loyalty is
years later people come back which is
interesting nobody comes back to a video
game two years later so you stare at
this and you say that's that that was
the start of dynamic pricing
okay we've got an issue here so I'm not
seeing the how does it get over there
okay and now I click full screen okay
and now I allow sorry man so when you're
dealing with digital content you're
sending digital media to a device
consumed by an end user well you can
actually negotiate you can offer them a
price and if they don't like it you can
offer them a different price later
that's not something the airlines are
really capable of doing it's sometimes
done in consumer packaged goods does
anybody remember Filene's of Boston they
had this really interesting price tag
system where they had like nine prices
on the tag and it was this week it's
this price next week it'll be that price
next week it'll be that and you could
actually go and find something you liked
and think okay I'm going to come back in
four weeks and if it's still on the
shelves that's the price I want so they
kind of had that in there you know are
there competitive markets at the
beginning when you first start playing a
game maybe but by the time you're at
level 100 and candy crush saga there is
no substitute for that you've invested
in that game you have skills in that
game you care deeply about that game and
there is no other supplier generally
available rate cards there's no sharing
of prices it's a fat thing on your phone
right it you can't let go go to your
friend and say hey you know you can't
email a URL like you can with amazon so
pricing can be personalized there's no
really pre-existing anchoring who knows
how much gold should cost in the new
game it's small repeated purchases
there's a training effect here and so on
so digital content turns out to be
radically different from hospitality and
compute sumer packaged goods at a 30,000
foot level well we're trying to target
the pricing at the consumer at the
detailed level the problem is completely
different and i just want to point this
out when you have a phone it's a
long-term persistent identifiers
you don't really give your phone to
other people right you're the person on
that phone by the way you installed the
app it's on the phone it's a notion of
identity in a way that you know when you
go to Amazon and you go from a different
computer you look up prices you you
don't install the game on multiple
devices contains a huge amount of
information it knows your location it
knows what's installed on it it knows
what's in memory it knows the device
capabilities screen resolution and it's
the point-of-sale device and this is
like the single creepiest slide you have
a personal identifiable personally
attached to you user specific device
with a lot of behavioral information and
it also happens to be the checkout stand
so plus you know there other things
happen here one of the really
interesting things this morning was a
lot of the talks were about I've got
astronomical data and it's got five
different date systems and one of my
challenges is figuring out which date
representation is in which piece of data
because I have data coming from all
these disparate sources and I'm trying
to make sense of the data well prices
modify behavior there's feedback going
on here if you know you know might say
well really well happy hour right it
creates demand it creates people going
to it you know be fearing practice of
happy hours actually subtle when do you
when do you have happy hours in the real
world when do you have them in games how
do they work do they change behavior
there's a really nice that you know
depending on whether you like it or not
it's the sunk cost fallacy once people
have invested they tend to invest more
because otherwise they made a mistake in
the original place you can't have that
so now in the game if you buy all of a
sudden that games much better because
otherwise you were really stupid right
so if you can get people to buy they're
going to buy again and you see this over
and over again so not only do we have a
structurally different problem but it's
got massive feedback loops in it
if you price right you get people to buy
more later on you've trained them the
art of buying and they are committed to
it and you know it's a sunk cost fallacy
or it's you know retroactive
modification to their impressions but
it's really interesting and of course
from a scientific perspective we are
finally in a position answer which is
stronger intertemporal price
discrimination or operant conditioning
so intertemporal price discrimination is
my favorite phrase of all time it means
waiting for a sale um you know no one in
the economics literature talks about
people waiting for sales they talk about
intertemporal price discrimination
effects and you stare at that and you
figure it out waiting for sales but it's
interesting because if you have a
discounting strategy and it's obvious
enough people wait that is in fact the
entire point of happy hour you know
people come at the appointed time to
spend on the sale at the same time your
conditioning people to spend money in
the game and there's going to be certain
impulses to do it and will people wait
for the sale or will they just buy
because they've been trained to do it
and of course we can tell with a fair
degree of accuracy when people are going
to stop playing a game so how do you
change your prices if you know someone's
about to leave do you so that's why it's
a big problem pretty interesting facts
about how people behave so first and
foremost there's a huge cultural effect
as well for reasons nobody understands
Brazilians really like city building
games they play the more they spend more
in them Germans hate them don't know why
but it's true you're looking surprised
okay turns out that you know
monetization depends a lot on income and
a lot on disposable income and you see
it all the time in terms of which phones
buy stuff you get this data from Google
Play almost immediately and you say
Nexus 7 is about three percent to three
percent of the market but it's six
percent of the span
consistently another thing that happens
is if people are still playing the game
after a certain period of time this is
from one of our games and faux pas our
code sorry but basically there's a point
at which somebody's been playing the
game long enough and they haven't spent
and now they're used to playing the game
without spending and so they're never
going to spend and in this particular
game it's eight days if they haven't
spent in the first eight days they're
just gone so that's interesting because
now you say okay that means on day nine
I should have a sale targeted at them
maybe lots and lots of other information
men who own Xbox ones tend to spend more
can you tell that from a phone it turns
out you can and if that doesn't you know
surprise you sorry more apps user has
installed etc people who buy earlier
spend more this is either a complete duh
or an opportunity well if they bought
earlier then they'd probably like the
game and if they like the game they're
going to spend more duh right this is
not a surprise but if the other hand it
turns out that if you pull spend earlier
you get that sunk cost fallacy working
for you and so this actually is a
self-reinforcing cycle so if you think
that somebody is about to exit that
eight days and you can pull them in
they're going to spend again and again
and again then you can modify behavior
which is really interesting and goes to
the heart of what i really want to
mention here and make sure is the key
point so again just a fact so does this
all make sense everybody get it any
surprises interest questions pausing
cool so
if you read the popular press and
actually somebody this morning reference
bjs book and I was very happy about that
there are all these books about
behavioral psychology and behavioral
finance and behavioral economics and
they all make these claims and they all
say you know if you do this you know I
mean predictably irrational has the
example of the bread machine worth
reciting cool so basically some
manufacturer whose name i forgot
discovered that the way to sell more of
their high-end bread machine was not to
reduce its price but they introduced a
new even more super premium bread
machine because when people go to the
store to buy bread machines that make
bread for them they don't want to buy
the really expensive thing because
culturally people don't want to feel
like they're being really extravagant so
what you do is you essentially set up a
decoy and it's it's the bread machine
that no one's ever going to buy because
it's 1,900 bucks and it has gold plated
buttons and its whole function is to
make the 499 more bread machine look
reasonable and all of a sudden you
introduce this high-end thing and boom
your cells shift to the right and more
people buy the previously premium bread
machine it's an interesting thing
there's only one question you know is it
really true does that actually happen it
happened for bread machines at least
ones that we know of and on the basis of
that we have a book and we have many
chapters and we have many speakers going
to many conferences talking about this
new revolution and pricing strategies
namely introduced really expensive stuff
nobody will buy to make the other stuff
look reasonable and does it work and
interestingly enough if it does work
there's a fascinating thing which is
that at least half these books are wrong
right because you know if you go and
read a micro economics textbook it has a
demand curve and it has a supply curve
and it talks about how you know people
have price points and so on and so forth
and then you go back and you say wait a
minute you don't have a price point you
have sort of a situational price point
that changes if I introduce a more
expensive bread machine wait wait wait
wait wait wait so those curves in check
after three what are they really and
it's interesting because you know these
guys have not ever actually empirically
tested their stuff in any large scale
but neither of these guys and that's
interesting because we have 300 years of
economic theory most of which has been
untested in the real world so it's worth
pointing that out repeatedly and now you
know if you think back to my comment
about a hundred million hours in clash
of clans daily you can sort of see where
I'm going we can test this stuff and
then we also have all of these textbooks
but they're not text books there you
know manuals for game designers they're
brilliant books they're semi academic
books and that people stop and say what
is a game really and begin by rejecting
Vic and steins you know nonsense and
then talk about how you structure game
how you design a game what makes a game
engaging etc and these are all really
textbooks on human behavior but they're
written from a practitioner point of
view not an academic point of view and
of course we have grandpa you know good
old BF Skinner who no one ever reads
anymore talking about how behavior can
be modified and you take all of this and
you say things like this should never
happen again so this is a paper from
2013 about violence in video games and
it claims to substantiate the idea that
people who play violent games are more
aggressive and violent in real life and
it does so in the following way we took
two video games won a violent game in
one a non-violent game and we handed
them each to approximately 100
undergrads at the University of Iowa and
they played for four hours on to the
violent game or the nonviolent game and
then we read them a story well the first
part of a story and then we asked them
what they would do if they were the
protagonist and they reported back on
how they would behave in the story and
what we discovered is that when we peep
the people played the violin game they
had more violent responses in the story
and you sort of stare at that you say n
equals 224
but that's what is that that's noise
there's not enough data there to draw a
conclusion and the actual thing that you
studied was self reporting based on a
hypothetical imagine you're the
protagonist after playing in violent
video game and by the way there was
apparently only one type of violent
video game the violent video game they
chose and all violent video games are
the same and you stare at that you say
ah you know I would fail anyone who gave
me that you've turned that work in my
class but it got repeated in over a
thousand articles in 2013 as part of the
great debate over whether grand theft
auto 5 fostered antisocial tendencies we
can do a lot better we had these games
they have how many players I've got to
go way back for that but fifty eight
percent of Americans are playing an hour
a day we've got a vast amount of data
here we've got we know that people play
differently and we've got all these
books and all these theories and all
this speculation on human behavior over
the past yeah these are all from the
past ten years these are from the past
300 years and by the way i think the
wealth of nations is a great book by
saying it has untested but testable
hypotheses i'm not saying it's a bad
book i'm just saying we can now actually
determine whether it's a true book we
have other theories of how people behave
and we had the current state of the art
and behavioral science which is to ask a
bunch of undergraduates how they behave
in a hypothetical situation and then
summarize it so this is actually
something I'm really fascinated by my
comfort this is Ted castronovo he's an
economist at the University of Indiana
and he has an open offer saying that he
will work with any game company anywhere
to help them design economic systems
because he is really curious about what
makes for good money classically there's
a definition of money you know store of
value highly fumble etc his point of
view is you know now that we have
essentially these enormous petri dishes
we call games we can actually test
makes for a good economic system we can
actually test core assumptions that have
been embedded in the way we think about
economies for 300 years and that's kind
of fascinating so where are we right now
this is just you know my company we
actually have an economic system up and
running we have customers there live we
are doing things like if you remember
back that slide that said you don't buy
it after eight days well then we should
start offering you discounts on day 14
why not it's an experiment can we change
that curve and we have enormous amounts
of semantically rich and clean data
puddling up right now one of the really
interesting things this morning was a
lot of conversations around cleaning
data or understanding what data means
we've essentially built SDKs so that we
get the data it clean we don't know what
it means and we have these feedback
mechanisms that are not present in other
systems but at the same time we have an
enormous amount of data is starting
gather and it's all about behavior so
that's what we're doing that's the talk